This is a simple example of the Geolocation API, you
call getCurrentPosition and pass it a call back and the
call back is called when it gets your location and
gives you your latitude and longitude. There's also a very
similar watch position call, which does the same thing except
continually calls you every time the position is updated. Let's
walk through how we use this API in our conference
app. First, we added a button to the map page
that triggers the Geolocation procedure. When this button
is pressed, the triggerGeolocation method in our code
is called. This code is the heavy lifting
of the triggerGeolocation method. This uses the HTML5
Geolocation method API method, getCurrentPosition. And passes it
a success call back and an error callback.
It also enables high accuracy and sets a time out. In case of failure, we print
a generic, Sorry, we couldn't find your location.
On the other hand, if we succeed, we call
a method called elaborateDistance. ElaborateDistance uses the root
method from the Google Maps direction service to obtain
an object containing information about the route between
the user's position and the venue. It then displays
some of this information and allows you to
open up Google Maps with the route already set.
Obviously, this is frequently the way that you'll
use Geolocation data, that is, passing it off
to another control. Most of us don't, write
code that uses this latitude and longitude directly.